LOCAL AND NATIONAL ELECTIONS IN
THEIR FAVOR.
ROANOKE VIRGINIA IS REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN BOB GOODLATTE.
HE'S THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET TO ON THESE
TEXT MESSAGES, DISAPPEARING, THE
SECRET SOCIETY.
I WANT TO GET YOU ON THIS ISSUE
OF CHAIN MIGRATION.
I HEAR A LOT FROM DEMOCRATS
ABOUT HOW REPUBLICANS ARE NOT
ANTIFAMILY CONGRESSMAN.
AS YOU SAW WITH THAT VERY
DIFFICULT TO READ GRAPHIC.
WE ARE RESETTLING HUGE
MERIT BUT BASED ON DISTANT
FAMILY RELATIVES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN GOING TO BE
REUNIFIED IN ANY SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME BECAUSE THE AMOUNT AND
LENGTH OF THE WEDDING WAS SO
LONG THAT THERE IS NO REAL
FAMILY REUNIFICATION.
OUR BILL ALLOWS THE IMMEDIATE
FAMILY, SPOUSE, AND MINOR
CHILDREN TO COME INTO THE
FAMILIES.
BUT THESE EXTENDED FAMILIES DO
NOT BENEFIT THE UNITED STATES,
IN THE SENSE THAT A MERIT-BASED
SYSTEM WOULD WHERE PEOPLE COME
HERE BASED UPON EDUCATION, JOB
SKILLS, JOB OFFERS, AND
TRAINING.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED IN OUR
ECONOMY, NOT PEOPLE WHO WERE
COMING HERE BASED UPON RANDOM
NEEDS FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: 400,000 CONGRESSMAN.
>> EVEN MORE RIDICULOUS.
>> Laura: 400,000 PLUS PEOPLE
EVERY YEAR COMING IN ON AN
EXTENDED FAMILY OF CHAIN
MIGRATION.
400,000.
IT IS A COMPLETE SCANDAL.
I WANT TO MOVE TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THESE REVELATIONS
ABOUT THE FBI.
DISAPPEARING TEXT MESSAGES.
OF COURSE NOW, THE UNDERSTANDING
OF A FORMAT THAT THERE WAS A
SECRET SOCIETY DISCUSSED WITH
WERE TALKING ABOUT.
DOESN'T SOUND TOO GOOD TO ME.
SPECIFICALLY THE TEXT MESSAGES,
THE NSA HAS EVERY TEXT MESSAGES,
THAT WE CAN GET THOSE TEXT
MESSAGES IF NEED BE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> Laura: WE SHOULD SEARCH
EVERY PLACE TO FIND THEM BECAUSE
I THINK THEY STILL EXIST IN SOME
I THINK THEY STILL EXIST IN SOMF
I THINK THEY STILL EXIST IN SOMR
I THINK THEY STILL EXIST IN SOMM
SOMEWHERE.
I'M PLEASED THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
HAS MADE A COMMITMENT TO
INVESTIGATE THIS AND FIND THEM,
BUT WE SHOULD ALSO UNDERTAKE
WHETHER THERE IS SOME WAY TO
GATHER THEM FROM SOME OTHER
SOURCE.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT, BUT EVEN A
TEXT MESSAGES WE HAVE ARE
ALARMING AND THE SECRET SOCIETY
JUST HARKS BACK TO THE TEXT WE
SAW BEFORE IN DECEMBER, TALKING
ABOUT THE INSURANCE POLICY.
WE KNOW ONE THING FOR SURE, AND
THAT IS THESE PEOPLE, HOSTILE TO
THE PRESIDENT, HAVE NOT BEEN
CONDUCTING THEMSELVES IN A
MANNER THAT BEFITS THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATIONS.
>> Laura: HOW DOES ANYONE HAVE
FAITH IN THE INTEGRITY OF THIS
INVESTIGATION?
WHEN WE HEAR THAT AFTER -- IN
DECEMBER, WE COULD ALL TEXT
MESSAGES HAVE BEEN TURNED OVER.
THEY HAD THEM ALL BETWEEN STRZOK
AND PAGE AND A NUMBER OF OTHERS
AS WELL.
THEN YOU GUYS JUST WEREN'T, WE
ACTUALLY DIDN'T GIVE YOU FIVE
MONTHS, CRITICAL TIME.
MACK, OF TEXT MESSAGES.
NOW WE FIND OUT SECRET SOCIETY,
ALL THESE PEOPLE DONATING TO
DEMOCRATS, CONNECTED TO THE OLD
ADMINISTRATION, HOW DOES THE
AVERAGE PERSON THINK THE FBI
ISN'T COOKING THE BOOKS HERE?
I LOVE SO MANY OF THE AGENTS OF
THE UPPER LEVELS OF THE FBI.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
THERE ARE SEVERAL PEOPLE IN
HEADQUARTERS THAT WE HAVE A
ALREADY INTERVIEWED AND SOME WE
WILL BE CALLING BACK FOR FURTHER
QUESTIONING.
UNDOUBTEDLY, THAT WILL INCLUDE
FORMER DIRECTOR COMEY.
IT IS ALSO VERY TRUE, AS YOU SAY
IT IS ALSO VERY TRUE, AS YOU SA
SAY, THE MAJORITY OF THE FBI
WORKS HARD EVERY DAY TO KEEP US
SAFE AND COMBAT TERRORISM, TO A
THIS IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS
THE PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE WORLD, AND IS GETTING
BESMIRCHED BY A FEW PEOPLE.
THEY NEED TO CLEAN HOUSE THERE.
DIRECTOR RAY HAS BEEN TOLD THAT
BY A NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE FULL FAITH
IN DIRECTOR WRAY RIGHT NOW?
>> I THINK IT DIRECTOR WRAY
NEEDS TO SHOW SOME LEADERSHIP IN
TERMS OF RESPONDING TO THE FACT
THAT THERE IS A CRISIS IN THE
HEADQUARTERS OF THE FBI AND
CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE.
SPEAK >> Laura: WHY DO YOU
THINK ANGELA KATE IS STILL THERE
AFTER EVERYTHING LEARNED ABOUT
HIM AND APPARENTLY JEFF SESSIONS
HIM AND APPARENTLY JEFF SESSION
SESSIONS?
IT LEANED ON WRAY TO GET RID OF
THEM, AND HE SAID ALL QUIT.
THAT'S ONE REPORT OF ALL QUIT IF
HE GOES.
WHAT'S THAT ALL ABOUT?
'S ARE NO CHAIN OF COMMAND AT
THE FBI THAT MATTERS?
STEP.
I THINK THE DIRECTOR HAS MORE
WORK TO DO.
>> Laura: AND CONGRESSMAN,
BEFORE WE LET YOU GO, THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION SEEMS TO
BE VERY LEAKY OVER THE LAST
24 HOURS.
WE LEARNED THAT JEFF SESSIONS
HAVE BEEN CALLED TO TESTIFY.
THEY ARE LOOKING TO BRING IN THE
PRESIDENT TO TESTIFY ON HIS
FIRING OF COMEY AND OTHER
MATTERS.
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LEAKS COMING
OUT OF THIS VERY HIGH PROFILE
AND IMPORTANT INVESTIGATION,
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO BE
GETTING NEWS ON OTHER FRONTS BUT
STILL >> IT'S VERY CONCERNING.
THIS IS NOT A HUGE ORGANIZATION.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT YOU ARE
OPERATING AN UNBIASED,
IMPARTIAL, AND EFFECTIVE
INVESTIGATION THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE A CONTROL OVER SOMETHING AS
BASIC AS LEAKS BY THE RELATIVELY
SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING THAT WORK FOR THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
>> Laura: IT INDICATES AGAIN
THAT THERE IS AN ANIMUS TOWARDS
THE PRESIDENT AND ARE ONLY
LEAKING STUFF THAT IS NEGATIVE
TOWARDS THE PRESIDENT.
OTHERWISE, IS THE LEAKS OF ALL